hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about forms one two and
three and how they interplay I really
think you're learning the vast majority
of the material in 1 two and three
there's lots of other little lessons you
need but mostly the Lessons Learned in
Form 1 2 and 3 are repeated over and
over again in the other forms because
Form 1 2 and 3 basically talk about
transitioning kinai and Skai and why you
would transition kinai and Skai and how
you would deal with a person being in
either or transitioning to either um
when a situation arises so one two and
three really deal with a lot of the meat
of what I think the Kumi Joe are
teaching I think cyto Sensei Kumi Joe
are basically talking for the most part
about how to get a distance Advantage
whether that be close-up dist advantage
or long- range distance Advantage how
you transition to that advantage and how
you deal with someone transitioning to
an advantage and I think that's the
majority of material years ago as I
started pulling it apart I realized I
was like oh this is what this is really
about there are some other things right
how you would deal with someone if you
were not in a ready to fight position
and that's what a lot of the other forms
talk about in fact after we get past one
two and three they all describe that
kind of situation so there's a lot of
that in there too but the main ideas are
how we deal with distancing and that's
something that I feel like I didn't
learn in the traditionally ew system
even though it was built into the system
it wasn't until later that I had those
problems with distancing that I was like
oh this is actually explained to me in
the form I just was too dumb to realize
it so anyway so we're going to talk
about one two and three I'm going get
Josh out here we to work
Josh all right so let's talk about uh
first form second form third form and
what they're doing um so first off uh
first form second form third form are
the only three forms that are a heads up
situation and what I mean is we both
know we're engaged in a fight everything
else is going to be one person not ready
for some kind of exchange um but these
all three are ready for an exchange so
actually let's switch directions here
okay
so one of the most important things
taught here and taught in all these Kumi
Joe is transitioning jod guch and why
one would transition jodan guch so in
the first form we have out of distance
and Josh is going to transition Jordan
guch and he's doing that for a reason
because by transitioning jodan guch he
can cover the distance he needs to cover
here in order to hit me so we're out of
distance go back we're out of distance
for ski Kamai uh you're fine uh we're
out of distance for ski Kamai here so
meaning if I took a regular ski Kamai I
don't get Josh and the same would be
true for him he wouldn't get me but if
he transitions jodan Gayu he's covering
that distance and hitting me now look
that's what you want to be doing when
you're making a distance change is you
want to be actively making them do
something as well otherwise you're just
giving them more time to prepare for
what you're about to do so he doesn't
want to give me prep time as he moves in
he's going to be hitting me and that at
least makes me have to defend the shot
or whatever else I'm doing so that's one
way we can use it okay now in second
form we're in close so in uh second form
we're at a close range like this and as
Josh comes to get me I deal with this
with the mawashi barai now I can use the
ideas of first form here as well right
so meaning if Josh took that transition
so because were close if Josh took that
transition and tried to jod and G I
could hit him here and then cover right
so that's what first form teaches us and
I can use that idea in second form okay
also though I can use or Josh can use
that in order to avoid this right so see
he's pulling back from that so in first
form we have that idea that I can thrust
him on the offbeat while he's prepping
the high action and then still defend my
head but Josh can now use that same idea
the transition J to make this instead of
come in and so if I tried that idea here
he could pull back boom and I'm not
going to be able to get him right so
this is where we see first form and
second form inform each other right so
they're informing each other about what
we could do if at any point Josh felt
like I was going to hit him on the low
line using joden guch he could pull back
okay now we get how do I cover that
distance in second form teaches us how
we cover the distance if he tries to
back off right so in second form here
now look if I just shot here he'd pull
up but if I come up underneath I cover a
huge amount of distance and I do it in a
protected position so meaning if he was
fast I'm in Boni noay that entire time
to protect myself so these two inform
each other immediately about things that
are going on right okay now when we get
to third form we're seeing what happens
if you get crowded from the kinai
position which is usually off of the
transition the other two forms off the
transition but let's say I'm in kinai
okay and so this guy's coming in so now
look The Stance wise what's happening is
we're close range and Josh is in the
superior Kamai for close range my
weapons over here to the side which
means if I wanted to use this to defend
myself it'd be kind of difficult and
yeah I could Whack Him but what good
would the whack do cuz I'm still going
to get gotten right so how can I change
the way I'm using this weapon so now if
I was the one transitioning into longer
distance stance how can I use as he
comes in the backside to defend myself
right so this if I'm in Kenai and we're
close range how can I defend myself
close range this is how right okay now
what this does and so there's lots of
ways I could attack from here but the
form teaches us to turn it all the way
around now what's cool about that is
this turning also puts me back in this
position so if I wanted to use it for
either first form or second form I could
so watch what I mean by this it's really
cool so after I hit Josh He transitions
juch right so let's say he transition go
ahead and comes here and hits me all
right now if I'm faster than him I can
use first form boom right okay faster
than him first form first use first form
if he detects that and go backs up then
I can use second form to come in after
him right so I can deal with him whether
he's backing up or crowding me with
first and second form so are there any
other ideas yes and this form teaches us
the third idea in there which is after
this defense I can still go here and
that's if he's too quick for me to do
either of those other two ideas right
those other two ideas require me to get
here to stab but if I get here and I'm
kind of junked up then as he comes
around I can just use this to just knock
it away right so it's a crude Parry but
that is another idea that I might get if
I'm not quick enough to turn those other
two over so in third form if we get here
and as he slow down a little for me as
he's transitioning I'm quicker than him
I can get him here if I'm quicker than
him and he detects that so he starts to
back off I got to be a little slower
than that I got to I'm going to come up
from underneath him right does that make
sense so either way I can can deal with
those two situations now if I'm not able
to do either one of those so I'm not
quicker than him then what happens is I
can use this side to defend myself right
now once I get over here if he R in zoku
I could do either of those things again
right so if I'm quicker than him I can
go here and defend first form okay if he
detects you got to slow down as if he
detects that and backs up for me I can
track him down and Whack Him from
underneath right so I could do those
same things on the other side as well
and this perform shows you how to set up
to do both of those things now now what
happens third answer again if I'm not
fast enough doing either of those as he
comes in I whack him here boom okay now
we learn another important thing here
and until we get into fourth form which
will be coming up this week um we won't
see what the other answer is but the
first of our answers from this is we're
now close quarters and I'm Stick Over
the Top in this position so I'm in heo
me Stick Over the Top I can come in here
and I can set up a choke and I can set
up a CAG right and so this form teaches
us when we're close quarters we can deal
with that okay now let's talk about
Close Quarters so we're going to get
close quarters answers in forms 1 2 3 4
five 1 2 3 four five sorry 1 2 3 four
five we're Get Close Quarter answers for
all of those so the first half is all
Close Quarters answers so this is one of
our Close Quarter answers but what are
our other ones so like let's put Josh in
Ken Kamai again okay so I'm either going
to be in this kind of position or this
kind of position right or I'm going to
be in this kind of position or this kind
of position those are the ways I'm going
to be and I could of course be either uh
thumbs back or thumbs forward in those
situations right okay now this form
third form after I'm here I go into this
set okay in fourth form I'll show you
when we get there but we could do that
now let's say I'm underneath the arms
well this is the answers from second
form right here's second form answers
right and it might not look like that to
you right now but let's just show you
second form so we're going to go back
here and do second form so we get in
here when he comes in boom and I come up
underneath good you're okay I just want
to show this part okay so I'm here like
this right now I'm underneath those arms
right and so if he comes for me I can
turn here there's second forms ending
also though if he went to the other side
that doesn't change for me right it's no
different it's the same answer we only
see it in one side in the form but it's
the same either way so if I'm underneath
the arms there we get that that uh that
method okay now first form I'm on the
inside so I'm here actually sorry let's
switch around this direction so I'm here
like this okay so this is the opposite
side so before stay right there for me
stay right there for me so before I was
here right okay now I'm here on top and
I'm thumbs forward right so here I hook
in there as he raises up to get me I
follow him over boom and throw him over
right okay so we're seeing three and
we'll see uh two more in a second but
we're seeing all the possible variations
for Close Quarters and those all feed
each other right so let's say Josh had
just finished a strike boom I came over
the top like this and let's say he just
blew past this he just goes straight up
boom now I'm inside here right and so
this is our second form stuff right okay
let's say when we did this right for
whatever reason I got turned around and
now we have all this set of answers when
we're in here right so same same thing
same thing same thing so first second
third form they're all heads up forms
meaning we're in engagement we both know
we're in engagement they're talking
about how you transition the distance so
if Josh is trying to get the advantage
or if I'm trying to get the advantage
because I can take the lessons of I can
transition back or forward Nei one of
those how do we adapt to that when it
can happen what are the counters for
that and what are the grappling
situations that are likely to happen
after that so we get a ton in first
second and third form um the next two
forms are going to be really important
they're all important and they teach
different things but to me you could
probably get you know 70 80% of all the
work from first second and third form so
I think they're highly important okay
that's enough on this I'm Christoph this
is Joshua T my salon McDaniels behind
that camera right there and we'll see
you in the next video